in australia sydney welcomed in the new
year with its traditional fireworks
display and this one was a spectacular
as ever over seven tons of pyrotechnics
were shot into the night air
2014 has come to Japan bells rang out in
Tokyo and across the country thousands
streamed into temples and shrines
Japanese tradition holds that the first
hour of the new year belongs to the gods
in China celebrations got off to an
early start new year's day is officially
just a public holiday but the country
follows the lunar calendar so 2014 won't
arrive for another three weeks near
Beijing revelers bid farewell to 2013 in
style with live performances and a
spectacular laser show lighting up parts
of the iconic Great Wall oh I use not
yahoo elevate how no 2013 was a great
year for me she says I graduated from
school and got a job a big first step in
my new life in 2014 I want to learn to
be grateful and happy and I hope that my
friends and family will stay healthy
despite the recent terrorist attacks in
Russia Moscow saw in the new year in
style there was plenty for Muscovites to
enjoy
New Year's also marks the start of
Russia's longest holiday period in
Germany partygoers have been crowding
into the Capitol to greet the arrival of
the new year Berlin is in a party mood
some come back year after year to
celebrate
minus these women say they enjoy the
atmosphere here because they meet people
from all over the world lots of people
talk to us they say especially young
people they take photos of themselves
with us last time they were from Italy
and Poland people even come all the way
from Australia it's the biggest new
years eve party in Germany in Europe
there's tons of things going on you can
see how many people are here about a
million Berliners visitors and over 250
musicians will ring in the New Year next
to the historic Brandenburg Gate